there's a news report just came out of
australia
that some some fugitives are on the
loose
these fugitives did not commit
murder
theft arson
these days if you commit those crimes
you'll actually be celebrated as long as
you're a member of blm and antifa no
these men
they are fugitives not from
justice
but from
a covid
quarantine camp
we've been told the trio scaled the
fence in the early hours of this morning
police receiving reports around 4 40 a.m
now major police checkpoints have been
set up around howard springs for the
past several hours as you can see in
these pictures they've been conducting
far searches in car boots checking
vehicle registrations cars and buses
alike but in the last half an hour what
we understand is they've actually been
dismantled exactly why that hasn't been
confirmed hopefully good news we're also
not sure yet who these people are
connected with whether it's a
repatriation flight or those aboriginal
community members who have been staying
here following the catherine cluster
davina what we do know
is that this is definitely going to
bring this gold standard facility under
intense scrutiny on sunday we had a man
escape and found on darwin's party
precinct and his latest situation is
only going to put us under the
microscope further
so we're going to get all right forgive
my accent we're gonna get all the cops
out there and they're gonna bring him
back and drag him back to the detention
camp where everybody is being held
because of the virus all right back to
you how's the weather yeah yeah i
watching this clip
i
did not believe it was serious news i
thought it had to be the onion or
babylon bee or a satirical outlet
how the hell did we get here
how did we get to covet detention camps
in a western allegedly civilized nation
like australia how did we get here a lot
of people beyond the covid camps
beyond that specific issue
i want to get to the broader political
issue
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady in
scotland just like me your humble host
lord michael knowles all you need is a
one square foot plot of land and a
certificate established titles is a
project based on an historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you can even get a
couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified distinction you
will be able to have land right next to
one another at one square foot and you
will both get to be called lord and lady
you can get this on your credit card on
your plane tickets you can even put it
on your dating profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code knowles to save an extra 10
today
a lot of people thought this kind of
thing could never happen oh come on
don't worry about it
a lot of people thought that all the
kooky stuff that was going on on college
campuses in in recent years oh that'll
never get out into the real world it
can't happen
those snowflakes they'll get into the
real world and then they'll straighten
out what happened
the real world
bent down to the snowflakes
oh that'll
stop worrying you conspiracy theorists
there won't be covid detention camps
there there actually are right now in
australia and then there are huge
police chases trying to track down
people who escaped the covet camp
the problem
here for conservatives is a failure
of political imagination
it's actually a failure of imagination
and conservatives are especially guilty
of this because conservatives kind of
like the way things are and we're kind
of more normal and we're a little more
grounded and so we just think oh it's
fine they're never going to redefine
marriage
they're oh that'll never happen they're
never going to
redefine sex itself
that'll never happen
they'll never lock down the world for
two years over the wu flu that'll never
happen
they'll never have covid camps
in a western asia that'll never it'll
it'll happen it can happen it actually
can happen guys
and and this is actually a lesson that i
think conservatives can learn
sometimes when the more
uh eccentric thinkers on the right
the the thinker is a little more outside
of the mainstream i'm thinking of people
like patrick dineen or adrian vermeuel
or the the integralists or the i don't
know the people who maybe you haven't
even heard of these guys but they're
writing in a
a little more fringy way for the
mainstream right-wing thought
we think that can never happen that we
need to we need to lower our
expectations we need to make a deal with
the left we need to we need to concede a
lot of things to the left we need to
concede
on all of these cultural issues
actually maybe the fringier guys are
more correct maybe the fringier guys
have a have a
saner view
of the boundaries of politics maybe
actually our
our modest political aims in the
mainstream right have been our downfall
maybe we need to
think more imaginatively
and maybe we need to move that over to
window a little bit more where we're
just going to keep losing and losing
and losing hey man i'm glad you like
that clip or lady or whatever however
you identify thank you for watching that
clip you can subscribe by ringing the
bell getting all the notifications for
all the future videos and if our friends
here don't want to give you the
notifications i would recommend you go
to apple podcasts or spotify or stitcher
or google play or wherever you get your
podcasts
and subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]